el ministro de defensa de venezuela
vladimir padrino dijo que fue una orden
directa del presidente nicolás maduro de
contactar el ministro de defensa de
colombia para el restablecimiento de las
relaciones militares recordemos que
venezuela rompió relaciones con colombia
a principios de 2019 por orden de
nicolás maduro parece entonces el
presidente iván duque no reconocía a
maduro como presidente y apoyado al
dirigente opositor juan guaidó como
presidente interino de venezuela el
pasado 28 de julio el canciller de
gustavo petro visitó la frontera con
colombia álvaro leyva y allí se reunió
con el canciller venezolano carlos
farías se habló de una agenda binacional
para el restablecimiento de las
relaciones diplomáticas y un eventual
nombramiento de embajadores y personal
consular hay mucho expectativas con
respecto a la renovación de las
relaciones entre colombia y venezuela
países que comparten una frontera de más
de 2.200 kilómetros aunque no hay una
reunión prevista formalmente entre
gustavo petro y nicolás maduro ya
nicolás maduró enviados felicitaciones a
su homólogo colombiano y ha dicho que
esto sería una segunda oportunidad para
la paz entre ambos países